bill berger what happened of all time
this is the best
what do you what do you say i didn't see
billboard yeah
they were trying to cancel them for this
which is [ __ ] but it's good like
canceling bill bird you can't he never
acknowledges it
was that the only one who wanted to kill
himself during that piano solo
[Laughter]
this is the part that pissed it for me i
am losing so much money right now
all right shout out to all the rock
stars that i wanted to meet tonight who
are watching at home instead i'm talking
to you don dawkin
all right what i'm old that was my first
concert
all right here are the next categories
all right hey how many uh feminists are
like going nuts why is this this white
male doing all this latino
that was the part that just pissed gen's
ears off they were
they yeah they're all like you're
canceled you're canceled but he
never acknowledges it he just keeps
moving on and yeah
what are you go you can't cancel no one
can you can't end someone for that
dude people need to go you might get
kicked off star wars
maybe you know you give me a bunch of
[ __ ] yeah
okay who cares though no that wouldn't
affect billy it won't affect him one of
the greatest
[ __ ] comments alive this was the best
in response to it someone said uh
gen z calling billboard racist and they
showed a picture with him and nia his
african-american wife his black wife oh
my god look at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
bill burr is racist the white man having
a non-white wife can sometimes be a sign
so you shouldn't assume someone's at
racist just because they own a mind
own a my minority sex servant they may
very well have one because they're
racist oh no and
that guy should get punched in the face
and bill burr's wife responded with this
yes i love how people just lighten these
people up oh god because it's over
it's all very hard everyone's sick of
your [ __ ]
you gotta move on
the king in this game